Now you have some useful
parallel tree algorithms.
One is built on top of
work optimal lists.
And the other on the rate
compressed framework for
evaluating expression trees.
Now before wrapping up the lesson,
I wanted to point out one of the neat
ideas common to these methods, which
is the idea of linearizing the tree.
Why is that cool?
Well linearizing helps you achieve load
balance which is what you need to make
a practical parallel algorithm scale.
As an analogy imagine that
I gave you a pretzel and
I asked you to cut it up
into say seven equal pieces.
Like leaving the house and forgetting
to put on your pants, it's awkward.
But if you unroll the pretzel
back into a line,
it becomes much easier to measure
out into equal sized parts.
Though I know what you're thinking,
it will be a lot more fun to just
eat the pretzel,um.
That is delicious pretzel.
I doesn't taste like rubber at all.